londres deuxième jour du procès en appel
de julian assange en vue d'une
extradition vers les etats-unis où le
lanceur d'alert l'isq cent soixante
quinze années de prison accusé d'avoir
diffusé des milliers de documents
américains classés confidentiels très
affaibli julian assange a refusé de
comparaître aujourd'hui après avoir
participé à une partie des débats par
visioconférence ses soutiens restent
nombreux devant la haute cour de londres
ils ont même bloqué une rue de la
capitale plus de précisions sur place
avec à notre envoyé spécial katia
technique
aujourd'hui pour le deuxième jour de la
demande d'extradition en appel les
avocats de julian assange se sont
exprimés hier à james lewis le
représentant les états unis auprès de la
cour a contesté dans tous ses détails
l'expertisé psychiatrique est permis ou
lanceurs dallaire d'échapper à
l'extradition les américains tout
simplement ni le risque suicidaire qui
était le pivot de la précédente décision
l'avocat de julian assange a aujourd'hui
assuré que l'état mental d'une horde
alerte était de nature à déclencher des
envies suicidaires que quelles que
soient les conditions de détention aux
états unis il pouvait attenter à sa vie
il rappelle surtout la loi britannique
elle protège ce type de prisonniers qui
ont des troubles psychiatriques c'est
vraiment la clé de la défense de julian
assange alors que de terribles menaces
planent sur lui en cas d'extradition on
écoute le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks
kristinn hrafnsson
bien qu'ils essaient de minimiser cette
possibilité les charges contre lui
pourrait le mettre en prison pour cent
soixante quinze ans ça pourrait être
l'issue de son procès en plus de cela il
serait mis en isolement c'est une
certitude quoi qu'ils essaient de dire
il clame que leurs garanties soient
solides mais elles ne le sont pas
c'est l'estimation d'amnesty
international et de tous ceux qui ont
connaissance du dossier
l'avocat de julian assange a aussi
rappelé que la cia avait engagé des
discussions pour éliminer du là assange
ou encore le kidnapper et que cela en
disait long sur le traitement qui
pourrait lui être réservé aux états unis
sans oublier le vol de documents
d'avocats dans un bureau les filatures
de sa compagne l'espionnage à
l'ambassade equateur les analyses adn de
couches volet d'un fils de julian
assange on parle de tout cela avec le
père julian assange
cette affaire c'est comme un zombie qui
revient du monde des morts scandale
après scandale ils nous ont accusés mais
le témoin islandais que le fbi à
soudoyer pour témoigner contre julian a
été mis en prison c'est un pédophile
condamné un fraudeur condamné et il
s'est rétracté
même l'espionnage de julian par la cia a
été révélée à tout le monde trente
agents de la cia ont témoigné au
reporter de yahoo news un autre scandale
le parquet de la couronne et le parquet
suédois qui conspirent ensemble pour
garder julian à l'ambassade aussi
longtemps que possible jusqu'à ce qu'ils
trouvent un moyen de le capturer et de
le traîner devant le tribunal pour
extradition vers les etats-unis un autre
scandale
voici les éléments de plaidoirie de
l'équipe de défense en cette seconde
journée d'appel qui compte bien sûr
conforter la première décision alors
qu'ici à londres des centaines de
personnes se sont mobilisées depuis hier
contre l'extradition du lanceur d'
alerte le délibéré sera rendu dans
plusieurs semaines